thank you hi everybody I'm Philip and
this is Devon it both had students at
Berkeley and we will show you a system
that we've been working on and together
with a number of collaborators and for
Berkeley and Oakland industry for me
present is my first I'm excited to be
here and looking forward to meeting you
and attacking fear
so what is right general purpose
framework for a stupid plan together
with a number of higher-level libraries
and for I have lots and you can think of
right as something that you would use in
the same way that you would use my task
or my spargle salary so it's that type
of system and infused from paralyzing
and distributing practical so here's the
machine learning ecosystem today and
there are many parties that arise there
and maybe you think first of training
but it's actually much broader
so things that important outlets that
arise from machine learning recruits are
also serving
streaming things like distributive
reinforcement learning and data
processing and tidal primal attached so
today each of these systems is
implemented as a standalone distributed
system here's some examples of systems
that people use so they may use like
some robot for the Supra training and
maybe clipper or chance of recovering
for serving and then they use things
like price power or gas for their
processing and each of two systems are
specialized and very good at what they
do
but this poses serious challenge for
applications that are cross-cutting that
needs a lot of these different
capabilities so and this is especially
true for a class of applications called
reinforcement learning and which is an
area of machine running and which aims
to learn how an ancient should act
within the environment and in these
applications maybe you have higher
systems like alphago and from mind or
daughter from OPI and these components
are all very tightly travel together
within the same application and so this
is the primary address so I'm building
an emerging machine learning and reopen
on applications and require stitching
together out of these systems and these
are typically not the faithful with each
other and so this makes it hard to
transfer data across the system and also
m2m bring together these various systems
in terms of tolerance and in terms of
pasture management and so on
understand place is a burden on the
application developer so many so
therefore many machine learning
researchers actually build custom
systems to support their records and so
medium moving from is parallel from this
paradigm page component is a standalone
system and to something where we have
one unified system to support all of
them and so the real potential and comes
from applications that I use a lot of
these capabilities in one application so
if your muscle building and not only the
system but also the library is not
happened so for example we have a pretty
mature a reef hospital at this point and
we have pretty much phenomena such a
library
a library for the stupid training and
also potato processing which we look
into later so how does the system right
so on top there's all these libraries
and then it provides two abstractions to
many functions which mirror the way that
people typically do programming so you
write programs for any functions and
writing classes and we allow you to
easily distribute both of these concepts
so for functions and we have tasks and
these are stateless functions that can
run anywhere that cluster and can be
used for things like there are
processing for example and for many of
these modulus is also very important to
support stateful computation and for
that we provide and we make it easy to
distribute classes and is had an for
contact us which are classes that can
live anywhere the cluster and can be
used to distribute
staple things for examine parameter
service or think about a reinforcement
running similar tasks we are good for I
can't be a game which has some internal
state and that needs to be kept around
in the cluster and it's a long-running
process and that you can attacked with
this is our build on top of one and
back-end which is learning C++ and that
dynamic tasks abstraction so this is a
youth to get our the performance and
also provide one unified and warrants
mechanism it allows you to easily
recover from failures so let me talk a
little bit more about to the right API
now and let in tutorial you will all be
welcome in exercises and go through how
to actually paralyze applications with
this IP I so the starting point here you
want to make it very easy to take
existing applications and then
distribute them so the starting point
here is functions and my family function
which calculates 0 matrix and another
function which I'm going to sit upright
of two matrices and not actually stupid
them you and put in front of it this
rate of remote decorator and this makes
the function into remote functions which
can then be executed anywhere in joste
to invoke it and you call a function
name thoughtful mode of some arguments
and this will immediately start
accommodation the background and return
a future so pecan is an object ID and
you can launch and many of them in
parallel and they will immediately
respond control and framework will then
schedule it in the background so in this
case we launch two tasks and then you
can pass these futures into other masks
and the end of scheduler will keep track
of the differences as you see on the
right hand side and will schedule and
the tasks as the dependencies become
available so in this case we submitted
I'm the matrix product between these two
Co matrices and then at the end when
you're done you can call right up cage
and which is going to materialize the
object and it might transfer it from a
different note and
we'll just have a patent object then in
the background or am constraints this
computation graph which is also useful
for tolerance so if one of the note goes
down and something has lost for example
I rather figure out what is the best way
to reconstruct it and then it will
transparently recover from the failure
so this is an almost half the API right
there so the answer is the book this was
the task if you I let's not talk about
the ecto API so actors are about stifle
services thinking about a web server or
parameters of our key value store or
even running simulator for example and
you use user present class and you put
in this Android remote decorator
by the way for these decorators both for
tasks and I trust you can also specify
resource requirements so in this case
you're saying I'm of cheap use equals to
1.so right let's schedule the actor on a
notice of GPO so it does guess it's a
simple Combinator which has an increment
method so we can instantiate the actor
was actually about robot this will
create a process on an elastic and we'll
make an instance of the class and then
we can call mass internet so in this
case we'll call the increment method and
I we call it again and then we can also
get results so note that these two guys
are seamlessly integrated so you can
launch actors you can pass actress into
tasks you can pass results from tasks
and response from actors are really the
same thing so you can part each of them
to tasks select us okay so if not
talking a little bit about the
architecture that used to support this
so the requirements here actually I'm
pretty high for many of these three
fulfil running applications or AI
applications you really need to do a lot
of compute and also potentially a lot of
data transfers so for example for
testable training every and couple of
milliseconds you need to synchronize the
gradients between machines and for
example for the real fun running
applications you need to do maybe
hundreds of thousands of simulations and
per second and so how do we support AK
so here's an example of a small raster
and with three notes and the Phenom of
processes running on these notes what
about the driver
so that it could be an ID - notebook for
example or it could be some script that
you're running but this is the process
that launches the computation and you
can submit and pass through it and then
there's a number of local processes
these are the ones that are executing
the computation and note that the rate
combination model allows you to do
things recursively so and the broadcast
can also launch new tasks this makes it
distinct from other programs like for
example Apache spark so then and each
node also has been as an object store so
this is a shared memory segment which
can be used to share the data and
between all courses in war machine this
is especially important in the modern
setting where on the slab by example you
typically have many cars per machine and
for this is an important optimization
because if you have say 64 parts you do
not want to have 64 out because of your
data and we are collaborating with a
project called Apache arrow that you
might be familiar with which we use for
serialization and which supports the
check memory and paradigm Verena and
then we wrote passing through retention
labrie on top of that which makes it
possible to its post these arrow data
types as patent and they are the objects
so actually i'm has now also been merged
into arrow and because we think that
it's a component that can also be very
useful for many other systems okay then
there is an object manager for node
which does the data transfer between the
nodes it reads directly from the objects
Thoren can write in the tree and then
Dave one
scheduler per machine and so our
scheduling architecture is what we call
a bottom-up scheduling so if the task is
submitted on a machine the scheduler
will first see if there's enough
capacity on that machine
so if and data updates are local and if
there's a lot on one of the CPUs and if
that was the case it immediately I'm
scheduling on the same machine and if
not it will figure out I'm glad to
transfer it and then put it on a
different
we'll be executed there yes
this component that we call the global
control store and this is actually a
very intense and proven to be a very
useful and have system design so this is
the database we use actually rather
charted redness and it stores all the
metadata about the computation so things
like the computation graph which tasks
have been executing and stuff like that
and this makes it possible for all the
other components of the system to be
essentially stateless so this makes
makes the system was capable because and
you can start new processes they can
pick up rather than the global control
store and take mark and then process it
and it also makes it much easier to make
that system fault tolerant because each
of the processes say plus so if one node
crashes then we can just restart in the
process and it will connect to the
global control store and I reload the
data from there it also makes it very
easy to debug the cluster so and we have
been building tools you will see the
value I am as pastor tutorial and you
can easily inspect the class of site see
which tasks are being run and seeing
error message does nothing like that so
get processing is something that's kind
of an important part of their life cycle
and so we've been working on a library
in for data processing on top of ray so
to talk a little bit about the
motivation for like how we approach this
problem I kind of want to take a look at
like the the data science landscape we
have this issue where we're building
we're building tools on the large scale
terabyte plus but they have different
api's different requirements even
different skill sets that they require
then tools that everybody knows and is
familiar with at kilobyte megabyte even
local gigabyte range so so there's kind
of this disconnect where I can't use my
tools that I learned
using for years on terabyte data and the
tools that are made for terabyte data
actually perform worse on small data
than these other tools so I end up
having to use different tools on
different data sets to do the same exact
thing this seems counterproductive so we
took the approach of accelerating pandas
by changing one line of code but one
line of code is the import statement so
normally you would import pandas SPD
instead you'll import mode and pandas
SPD the approach here is effectively to
allow you to use all the cores on your
machine and soon in a cluster I still
keep that one-liner code change it's
very easy to install just install it so
when we look at the pandas API
the pandas a guy is actually massive
that's probably why it's so widely used
is because it's very rich it covers a
lot of use cases it's it's just it's
very powerful API but if movie data
frame 280 plus methods series 280 plus
methods and then there are all these
operators that people use concat things
like that
they're useful for other things 40-plus
so if you're going to do this one line
of code change and had had this kind of
idea where would you even start well we
decided to take a data-driven approach
look at what the community is using do a
study so we did a giant scrape of cattle
we took we took basically all the
notebooks that people use to enter
competitions and to teach and to learn
and to play around even and we figured
out what people use and what we found is
that there a small set of operations
that people use very frequently and then
there's this kind of long tail of
operations that end up being used very
few times but after we have the study
now we can just implement things in the
order of their popularity and then we
have a good idea of our coverage instead
of going going after things that
kind of make us look good if that makes
sense so currently we support 71 0.77
that's very exact 71 percent of the
pandas api which represents about 93
percent of usage based on our study
series has not yet distributed but the
full API is supported but as we continue
building out like this distributed 1d
object we're gonna be able to actually
scale a lot of operations much better
you can think of like group by and
things like that
Multi index also has preliminary result
but now you may be looking at this and
wondering like well what happens if I
fall within that 30% that's that's
actually quite a bit right well valley
in default to pandas in mode actually as
of this past week so covariance is
something that people use but it's
something that less than half a percent
of people used in our study so we
haven't implemented yet and you see
whenever you run this you get this nice
warning that says defaulting to pandas
implementation that lets you know that
there's gonna be a performance penalty
effectively for converting a an object
to a singular pandas dataframe
performing the app pulling the operator
and then converting it back we do
convert it back at the end so that you
can continue using a lot of distributed
operations so yeah so right now system
it's available in Qatar I should check
it out and you're going to use it
obviously so I'm we've been having an
initial release last May we have an
increasing number of contributors and
also a death and an increasing amount of
action use cases at various companies
who we are working with and yeah so it
will go through I'm an editorial and
together for everybody who is watching
this video on the internet and you can
go to this URL and check out the demo 5
- up up there for everybody here I'm to
make it as loose as possible we actually
have set up a
on the cloud we have set everything up
so you can go to this website and then
use the password to login yes so that's
how you're taking an distributed are
allowing us to work with a little spark
are you doing the same thing from like
things that we do with spark that I'm
not gonna be equipment be able to do
like with high sparkle just this
complementation and then like that
so give me an example I grow some
baskets or something so right now we're
really focused on so my question was are
we planning on extending this beyond
data frames to maybe some machine
learning algorithms or something like
that and the answer is right now no
we're well mainly focused on the data
frame abstraction right now basically
the challenges that like 80% of the data
scientist time is spent cleaning and and
like collecting and extracting data and
so that's kind of why we focused on the
data frame because a lot of people tend
to use the data for an extraction - good
question
any like oh she just ran out of memory
before it becomes the problem right so
and you're talking about this in the
context of a dear for him yeah so so the
question was memory is a problem
whenever I'm like rather than computer
memory is more the bottleneck for you
know operating on large large data sets
so yes since so right now we we have a
similar architecture to desk in that we
we we do have a mess or in our like
remote partitions if you want but our
architecture overall is is quite
different in the future
the the data frame will be certainly
using Apache arrows representation which
is you know an in-memory polymer format
can be compressed and things like this
and so you'll get you'll get a lot more
like you'll get a lot more distance out
of the memory that you do have how to
pour is also something that we plan on
supporting to where you know we don't
have the support natively yet it's not
something that would be you know
terribly hard in the future we're
definitely gonna have this out of poor
edges
much smaller memory footprint even per
partition so that's your question the
first is like your number one utility
with pandas read CSV which I assume like
in a large environment people aren't
reading like 30 terabytes of data out of
CSV so how from a development
perspective how do you think about well
these are common that they're coming as
a data small and like how do you map to
things that you wanted to develop so to
get a sense of where this is going in a
future yeah yeah so well I mean the
future we're going to support the fully
pandas API but let me repeat the
question for a second out so the
question was we have we've shown that
read CSV is the most popular and this
function but that's just because pandas
is inherently single node and maybe the
capital data sets are also more
triggered towards or more biased towards
CSV data so yes our target our target
initially was helping pandas users
effectively get over this bottleneck of
being able to use and it's for that you
know we're moving into the point where
we're starting to transition to more
large-scale things cluster cluster
support that kind of thing in supporting
the bullpens API really really it will
give us the kind of like all the data
ingest they didn't just as something
that we're always working on anyway so
yeah
that's right okay yeah yes in the back I
had to follow up okay so like naturally
sequel alchemy becomes one of the key
thoughts about that into your system
applications thanks David see ESPYs like
you say that I don't want to hit a cloud
DB or add a delay or whatever to the
source there have you guys explored into
the different you know I hope it's worth
that ability DC source there other back
opponent of pandas surface about meaning
that they challenged with this because
so so not yet so for a minute whenever
you so we've only like highly optimized
a few things read CSV and park it the
rest of them actually just default to
pandas and so any behavior the pandas
actually supports will be supported in
that ingest that's not going to be the
case forever but you know the the
project is only eight months old or
something so as we continue you know as
it matures of course you know the things
that we support and the performance will
of course you know like I can't remote
in starting process like the very
specific problem that's a problem that I
have what was like a nugget that starts
your development break what particular
part of the achievement of a problem you
find so painful that you yeah so my
bacon reflection in machine learning and
AI applications and I've been working on
several applications where the computer
for bottleneck and but typically this
involved for example I'm building like
using a simulator to learn robotic
walking in that in a simulated
environment I mean this would take I
mean even so I I was paralyzed in this
was
money processing like pretty lunch note
but it took like eight hours for example
to do the training run and so um
finding a good solution for these self
applications where it involves a lot of
different pieces like lamination and
then you need to surf the model you need
to update the model relies on training
that thought the energy starting point
for that so if I can offer the mocking
thing and if then let implement isn't
right and you can actually not find the
same walking in like a little bit over
three minutes so that's a pretty much be
done and there's many actually emerging
applications for example on Fargo or the
maybe knock daughter from of me I where
you need to integrate all of these
things together and so the existing
systems and didn't really have the right
performance characteristics for this so
to provide one system that can support a
very wide variety of our clothes and
that's the motivating they weren't
imagined behind right are they any more
questions
so have you been able to log into this
anybody who has problems - hat
amazing okay so let's go through the
first tutorial together so there are
many more exercises that we will be able
to UM go through and so I've had online
so I mean if you're interested you can
go through them at your own pace later
but for now if that was this exercise
m01 so one of the exercises have a
description and you can read and it will
guide you through and what you need to
do so this is a very simple i'm
data-parallel example which shows us how
to make a function to remote function so
typically how the XS are structured is
first in part a bunch of things and then
typically this has some something
already defined for you that you want to
speed up so in this case there's this
flow function as a proxy for slowness
which has sleep for one second and then
if being called a number of times in
this case we just call it four times and
it's
with time the time you take the number
at the amount of time it takes and then
telethon number of results and more
seconds and then yeah typically part to
accessory and verifies if what you did
is correct so this case validus and then
let's ask our opinion the two long that
the too slow the time was too long so
now obviously post through paralyzed is
using right so um how we do this is be
and put that at rate of remote decorator
in front of the function which makes the
function to remote pattern and then when
we call it we say function dr. much and
then at the end we need to call right up
get so now we can average and then we
can see if not a fashion passes and it
passes so this was an extremely simple
examples just a faster and then in the
second exercise you will actually do the
same thing that fantastic pendency so
there will be multiple tasks and it'll
call each other and there will be
dependencies in passed so I have the
chest that you go through these things
at your own pace and the two of us will
walk around and have death problems and
you should just place your hands if you
run into any trouble
this session up thanks Devon for the
amazing tutorial please everyone let's
give them a round of applause
[Applause]